but yeah like what do we [ __ ] what is
that for yeah
and put this back in my pocket
water bottle back there
that is a good point I asked him can we
get you anything he's like no I brought
my own
condom got me no she doesn't acid two
years ago at singing Fest get out of
here yeah she got me good when did you
realize it uh she told me she was like
she was we're doing a roast roast of
Lewis [ __ ] who throws himself a roast
hahaha
but um
that was a great roast though it was a
fun Rose it was a fun roast but uh but
yeah Shane's [ __ ] murdered that's on
YouTube go check that out Shane Gill is
roasting uh okay boogie yeah
but uh yeah
let's put a pill in that on the way back
yeah but she got then she went up and
she was like Hey Ari how was that water
I'm like what are you fine it's awesome
yeah yeah people kept texting me like
you okay you're doing okay
we have these big bay windows like
floor-to-ceiling Windows in the hotels
they put us at so I just open the
windows way way up and took all the
sheets off the bed and just like like
stared out of Houston people were like
are you okay I'm like dude yeah I do
drugs [ __ ] this wasn't the plan
tonight but like come down yeah it's
just like I'm an acid yeah she got me
good
[Laughter]
um
being like oh [ __ ] yeah you got me good
he got me good I was like that's crazy
Bamboozled I mean it wasn't bad acid you
know
so it was quality yeah quality asset it
can't be that bad I mean that's great
how frequently are you doing acid not
that often that being dosed with acid we
were in we're at this Festival Valley
Vibes Bonnaroo got rained out we're
loading up our [ __ ] RV with uh with
supplies and then cut the call like it's
where it's flooded it's not covet it's
flooded I'm like what
so we're like where the [ __ ] can we go
Western Georgia there's a small they
said three stages and the stages were I
mean like this we didn't realize we
thought three massive stages I call it a
meth Festival but it wasn't it was just
fun country and and metal and um
and yeah one good we're testing all our
drugs because you have to test drugs
we've talked about this guys
there's [ __ ] fentanyl out there yeah
yeah yeah
um so our neighbors were like getting
some coke like how was it could I test
it which I thought it meant like let me
test them no no you put it yeah let me
try and see how good it is it's not
wasted yeah oh yeah that's good I'll
take a pound I don't know I don't know
what a weird follow-up to you gotta test
your drugs well I thought somebody might
stuff them in your face
um
um this was that same week in those four
Comics died so I'm in this Festival so
they tested like hey that's 100 pure
cocaine definitely buy from that guy
right then we he's got some acid test of
that like that's 100 not acid like what
is it like I think mescaline or
something and it had just been dipped
and the guy who's who like he's like I
[ __ ] all over my hands and he's like
[ __ ] I'm starting to [ __ ] fly and
we're like oh because it gets absorbed
and they adjusted it it was still wet
yeah and I was like you're gonna be okay
he goes yeah same thing he's like I do
drugs yeah yeah this wasn't a plan for
tonight but it is now the plan I'm at
the right place I'm at a festival in
Georgia greatest Festival in the world
Valley Vibes wow um yeah it was just a
good time and then we're like oh we're
gonna start testing we got and we got
out and we're like four Comics dead and
we're like we really gotta start testing
our [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah is there any
drug you won't [ __ ] with no I want to do
heroin so bad wait why haven't you done
heroin seems too risky you really have
addiction no no why would he lie about
hair who looks it looks like a little
heroinette I love it
no or never as like part of another drug
Matthew done math yeah we've all done
math yeah Speedy [ __ ] yeah yeah all
right I've never streamed that I'm a
straight mess you've done Adderall oh
it's [ __ ] methods and Adderall I
assume we're still meth sounds darker
though yeah yeah it sounds like cooler
oh that's crazy and heroin is the
coolest drug why I don't know it's just
so cool because it's bad yeah it's just
like it's like you know
writers and [ __ ] musicians in the 70s
it's like heroin dude Iggy Pop seems
like it's the coolest drive for sure
yeah no what's the coolest drug oh I
mean I'm sure it's cool for you no I've
never done it it's just of like if you
like seeing that good and throw it all
the way yeah
or but what are you dealing with where
you you were willing to throw it all
away that's the other thing yeah you got
nothing to do I think you took a chance
like no no I'll just try it once and
you're like that this road only goes one
place yeah but you got to be so sad to
always go there if nobody happy throws
it all away for heroin because you're
already feeling good but also like
you're at a party you're part like I
told this to uh my buddy banging it or
snorting it nobody's shooting at a party
oh nobody shoots at a party but
everybody who said just heroin they're
always like it's like how'd you do it
just shoot it or snort it or smoke it
they're like uh they always have this
Line in the Sand I'm like you're wrong
you think she's done Coke she's like 29
goes no way let me set up a situation
for you let's call her Sarah it's not
her name but I was like uh hey Sarah you
want some coke oh no I'm okay okay Akash
cope yeah sure uh Alice Coke yeah okay
sure all right Coke yeah sure Sarah you
want some coke sure I'm like all right
all right I'll do so yeah and he goes
[ __ ] yeah she's for sure on coke yeah
yeah but the heroin one is is tricky it
became popular in like the Hipster scene
heroin did yeah when this is like in the
last maybe five years and you're just
gonna tie into the hipsters that people
don't quite understand which is you just
you're in there that world you like you
like go there as you're like B level
periphery yeah yeah I'm in the periphery
yeah but like I've seen him partying and
it's it's a lot of like City kids and
it's like what is the naughty thing what
is it if you're if you're like a hipster
not like a hipster like I moved here
from Maine so I could like be myself
yeah but I'm talking about like someone
who genuinely is trying to be like
Counter Culture maybe weak Life Time
Square yeah those people
yeah
if you really want like you're gonna do
the thing that is the most uncool drug
and heroin is probably the most uncool
drug all the great writers were on it
yeah but they're probably on other [ __ ]
too we just don't give it the credit
like they're probably drinking whiskey
we're not like oh whiskey is what makes
you a genius you know when that guy's
eating that guy's face and like it's
it's marijuana Shut up dude I'm sure he
had weed in his system oh in Florida
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so there's Florida
in the system
what was that I don't know what makes
you face eat yeah he has some other [ __ ]
to even eat face yeah yeah hunger
minimum bare minimum
he probably asked the guy for money he's
like dude I'm hungry he's like I don't
have any [ __ ] money
yeah you like that cartoon when you turn
into a big chicken wing you know
didn't quite get there oh really yeah I
saw [ __ ] I was in my old backyard on
12th Street
um has nice cool backyard I loved it
anyway I went out there with the chick
who had done it a bunch smoked it off
the top of a bowl of weed and then like
it just kind of like laid back and I saw
on this tree I saw this big caterpillar
like like it was like five six hexagons
like that you know it's a big
caterpillar that comes off the tree just
looks at me for a minute I'm just
staring back at him he's just looking at
me it was like that long and he just
goes
nah and then just like went back that's
crazy yeah and I'm like what and anyway
I was that was like that's how much of
an atheist you are the seeing drug God
was like nah yeah
it's not that you don't believe in God
God doesn't believe in you yeah
I'm gonna believe in studio 54. yeah
and then I looked over the girl I came
out of it looked at I was like did you
get there she goes I died and came back
I'm like [ __ ] I didn't get it very
different oh that's crazy DMT sounds lit
too much that sounds fun Ayahuasca got
me there oh really yeah where'd you do
that in Ecuador ecuadoria oh you went
for the real ceremony in Amazon yeah
yeah
yeah yeah Neil Brennan was like how many
ounces they give you I'm like ounces I
don't know man it was a bowl full of
[ __ ] [ __ ] like maybe tip your head
back yeah a half a coconut yeah wait
what's okay so when when you wins it is
it is it okay is it you're still a
comedian yeah so you're still analyzing
this thing like is this cliche could you
get lost in it yeah I got lost in it it
takes you there okay Duncan said it said
Duncan's all the tie to all the
psychedelics yeah yeah yeah um uh and he
said that one of those got Timothy Leary
one of those like anytime you're
fighting like trying to hold on wearing
our mushrooms and like trying to hold on
he goes you just haven't done enough
because if you do enough of that [ __ ]
you're gone and it's just like is that
just admit yeah or like uh was it Marnie
not Marnie what was that Nicholas Cage
movie
Leaving Las Vegas yeah your favorite
actor No No Love Necklace what Andy man
Andy yeah and he tries the most powerful
asset he just goes like they do it well
he tips his finger and he goes oh he's
just like in another world yeah
um yeah if you take enough you're gone
so this was that that's like you're not
fighting that but initially are you like
looking them in the outfits and you're
like what the [ __ ] by doing here like it
is cool they're wearing a [ __ ] giant
three yeah you know as weird with
outfits I'm taking notes
[Music]
he's upset at all that for later I'm
taking those for later okay
drive it down get it all analyzed it's a
convince Whitey [ __ ] that's what I'm
going into those environments like oh
they really got these people duped like
feathers yeah I haven't seen a single
bird in the [ __ ] Forest like when you
get these feathers from like I would go
go in with that perspective I'd
hopefully get to the point where I
completely submit myself but initially
I'm going to be you're like what is this
yeah it's natural it's in the Amazon
everyone just does it it's not a big
deal
yeah we talked to one guy we were like
on a tour of the Amazon and we're like
there was a survey or something like hey
Is We I think we should need like Pig
anymore because we're like a week out
from uh yeah from this thing is one
thing like Ayahuasca is like oh yeah
sure you're okay seven days you're good
sure yeah we all have dude that I was I
when I was at this uh Hotel it's on
Navajo land right so like a lot of tour
guys and stuff from Navajo and yeah
build your [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying nice hotels on their land
literally I went on Thanksgiving it was
one of the most I didn't even realize it
I didn't even realize it Thanksgiving
and got the saddest Happy Thanksgiving
on the ride to the airport that morning
she's picking us up at six or more Happy
Thanksgiving like literally shoulder
slunked my wife stole a dream catcher
from the [ __ ] hotel like we can't
take it take this home I'm like babe you
can take whatever you want
follow your dreams they do not fight
back don't take it
so so I'm talking to one of our guides
this guy uh this guy Dylan who is who is
great and um and and I asked him I was
like yo what are like the stereotypes
like a munch your cells like break down
the different tribes and [ __ ] like that
and like takes a beat he goes all right
I got you because the Utes they're the
idiots like and they just started it was
like there's they're no different than
growing up in New York in the same way
Jersey
and it was so cool to see
very good but they all did the reason I
said this because uh they all do peyote
and it's a family affair it's not like
not look down on it's not looked down it
is when somebody passes like the family
comes together and the kids do it they
don't look at it as a drug that's for
adults they look at this like
Transcendent experience that allows you
to like connect with I think uh maybe
the afterlife or whatever it is that
they believe in but I thought that was
really cool a way to look at drugs like
they didn't think seriously fighting
yeah they saw an old pre-columbian art
they were all like yes it's the Warriors
and the shamans on the same level of
like respect it's like it's all part of
like spiritual warfare versus yeah like
a literal War yeah interesting but I
thought that was interesting right like
you're letting kids do it yeah it's not
looked down on it all it's not drugs
you're gonna do it that's the other
thing it's limited right it's limited to
these experiences like God forbid people
die Etc told us yeah that he was like
all these different experiences and
people like [ __ ] with it which he was
like don't [ __ ] with it he goes don't
eat meat you don't have sex for this
many days it's only meat for this many
days fish is okay a
um and then afterwards it's this many
days lists and his wife came to visit me
right then so their silver isn't like
perfect I'm not allowed to drink anyway
um but he's like don't [ __ ] with it
because there was this one couple that
it was like six days out they're
supposed to go eight days they're like
we're good you know and they had started
they started fighting immediately they
broke up within a year whoa yeah
um but he's telling us all these
different experiences one of them
the crazy well one of them was like this
this guy who was like him and his chick
always had this like every seven months
kind of fight like he doesn't want kids
she does
and then standard story put it in the
back burner it was just going to rear
its head again put it in the back burner
it's going to rear his head and they
they did this Ayahuasca together
and they both just so you know step back
from yourself and they're just like oh
we're just not right for each other
whoa and then just broke up he goes 10
years later he's friends with her family
and her sees sees her kid sometimes
because it was just like clear it's like
yeah I do love you but this is I you
want all these things so what do you
think this is it just helps you see
clearly mushrooms does that too it takes
you out of yourself so you get to look
at this guy and you don't know a little
you know you make assumptions about
people
so you're based on limited amount of
knowledge about that person but you know
everything about that person because
it's you yeah and so with knowing
everything about this person but having
no ego attached to it that's what they
call it where it's like and like oh that
guy's just still mad at that chick for
breaking his heart yeah oh there's been
plenty of guys like that you can't get
mad at him for that yeah or that guy try
to [ __ ] that guy's girlfriend oh that
guy was me uh one of my medic some guy
[ __ ] my ex-girlfriend
like God probably doesn't give yourself
advice yeah yeah exactly and then you're
like you just get calm you're like this
isn't news it's crazy that we need drugs
to empathize with what someone else is
going through yeah and why they're why
those why those interactions they're
having are affecting the way that
they're treating us yeah yeah it's just
like a pause there's a little bit of a
moment where you stop going why is the
world happening to me and then you start
going what the [ __ ] could they be going
through yeah not only other people
you're saying you're able to see
yourself see yourself yeah yeah or like
you see like I'm just doing my first big
mushroom trips in San Diego with
Hinchcliffe and and damnedonia and a
couple other people and uh then we're
outside we're seeing all these like
homeless Beggars I'm like but then for
the first time I was like oh they just
got a different drug than I did they
caught crack and I caught weed it's like
here's ten dollars like sorry you know
it's not your your friends just
introduced you the wrong [ __ ] yeah yeah
you see yourself like calm down I've
call people and just forgiven them like
it's over it's over just why what am I
holding onto this dumb fight for
eign
what drug changed you the most and when
was it Boomers for sure
mushrooms okay so yeah yeah yeah yeah
mush is for sure did allow it allow you
to kind of like uh let go of that
resentment yeah resentment and I'm like
holding back for yeah and just like
little things of like I remember Chris
Fairbanks had a delivery style that I
thought was really cool where he'd like
say something but he'd make a mistake
but then and I knew it well enough
because I seen him enough times you make
a mistake and then he like go off on the
mistake you know yeah he's like uh you
know it's like hey nice nice who's like
who's with whose imagine if I and then
you just go off but he'd say shoes wrong
on purpose yeah and I've never really
seen that style before yeah and then I'm
sitting in my car not able to drive yet
and I'm just like hey and there's
Facebook I'm like hey Chris that's a
[ __ ] great delivery style yeah I
should tell everybody this stuff more
yeah just be nice to people yeah help
people out you know help them out
[ __ ] promote their specials yeah yeah
[ __ ] done it's like yeah yeah I've been
there come on it feels really good it
does feel good it feels good yeah hey it
also feels good but a nice love oh
[ __ ] get your boss longer yeah yeah
hates that quick hit hates it hates like
the crack it's too easy for five minutes
yeah yeah I'm curious the first time you
did any of these drugs after leaving
like religion religion were you nervous
were you like oh this is the [ __ ] I'm
not supposed to do that's gonna take me
some place I should Mark's about to
leave bro
I blame his priests bro his priests
didn't come through on that wedding day
he had one shot man you took his line
for your for your cat I did I did you're
like sand and glass and God bro I had a
quick detection it was but I was like I
don't know something about looking at
that [ __ ] horseshoe band man I felt
so insignificant in the most beautiful
way it was liberating the insignificance
sometimes you get caught up in
significance and you think you matter
more than you actually do and that
thought allows you to create things that
are really maybe profound within the
time you're living in but it's also nice
to take a break from the self-imposed
importance and just look at how
insignificant things are and then go who
gives a [ __ ] like I'm upset if somebody
says something about me or they think a
way about me this is gone yeah instantly
so like get over that get over that
incident a week I'm gonna be upset for a
week if a fly is on a piece of cheese
yeah they're not like well I've been
doing this like I want cheese there it
is I'm having it that was the other
thing when we're walking back from
Horseshoe Bend I tried to take a picture
but it didn't work
there were I'm looking at this thing
that's 100 million years old right yeah
and uh there were so many people and it
was a sunset so everything was dark you
could barely see the people uh you just
saw their Silhouettes and this is gonna
sound so corny I don't give a [ __ ] uh
we're all ants we're all ants yeah yeah
and I couldn't see their faces or
anything I just saw these dark
Silhouettes just like ants and on this
thing that was massive these tiny little
creatures are crawling on this thing was
massive and I was like oh my God that's
what I see ants doing all the time when
they're crawling in a flower bed or
something like that and then that moment
I'm looking at the thing that's already
making me feel insignificant now I'm
looking at all of us slowly walking
around on this thing that it's taken
hundreds of millions of years to build
there's no buildings nothing around us
and I'm like [ __ ] I'm I cannot let the
littlest [ __ ] bother me anymore yeah I
will and I will yeah yeah you'll get
back to it but I hope I can have moments
like drugs not at all but sometimes I
can get those highs without drugs like I
felt the highs I've experienced from
like Molly and ecstasy through
um not for as long and not as sustained
but I've gotten there just through like
amazing experiences I've had somebody
tell me like meditation will get you
wherever mushrooms gets you any of those
psychedelics and it's like they said
explain it like imagine if like
someone's knocking your door
you could get a butler or go open the
door for you or you could just learn
through meditation to get up the
mushrooms are the or the butler I like a
butler that's the thing
[Applause]
the doors
for hours
yeah
if I read the back story in this [ __ ]
Fast and Furious film I can enjoy them
more
you know like what are you talking about